ces photos et vidéo en attestent il
affichait un bonheur sans tache au japon
narumi nicolas fils est un parfait amour
jusqu'à ce que la jeune fille s'envole
pour la france et commencent à
s'émanciper la cour et peluches
minutieusement les messages de plus en
plus menaçant que nicolas zepeda adresse
à l'étudiante elle s'arrête sur cette
vidéo postée en septembre où il aimait
des conditions pour que leur relation se
poursuivre il bloque son compte facebook
parce qu'elle refuse de supprimer ces
contacts masculin en particulier arthur
de l' piccolo celui qui prend sa place
dans le coeur de narumi les parties
civiles attaque vous demandez un harumi
d'être une meilleure fille c'est quoi
une meilleure fille elle doit payer
c'est à dire expliqué nous diriez vous
que vous êtes un homme maladivement
jaloux encore très attachés à nicolas
narumi se défend supplice exécute
parfois naghmi est beaucoup plus jeune
que que cepeda
lls sous une forme de dépendance
affective avec lui ce son premier amour
elle ne perçoit pas réellement enfin que
deux parce qu'il exige cela ne
correspond pas à la norme à la normalité
d'une relation avec un homme donc oui en
ce sens il ya une forme de toxicité
sous le feu des questions nicolas zepeda
se défend évoque les mensonges de narumi
la famille de la jeune japonaise souffre
en silence pudique jusqu'au bout mais
alors que la nuit s'installe dehors les
lignes bougent à l'intérieur nicolas
cepeda reconnaît qu'il n'était pas tout
à fait par hasard sur le campus qu'il
était peut-être jaloux finalement un
processus d' aveux par exemple c'est
quelque chose qui qui se fait dans la
douleur dans la souffrance psychique
mental
et c'est pas évident donc là j'ai
l'impression
qu'il a commencé à faire une espèce de
travail et que ça pourrait être très
intéressant dans les jours qui combien
de temps encore nicolas zepeda
pourra-t-il tenir sa ligne de défense ni
et le contrôle qu'il exerçait sur narumi
ce matin à la barre un expert implacable
explique comment le jeune chilien
usurpait la connexion internet de
l'étudiante 150 conversation et pied
traduite jusqu'en octobre 2016 alors
qu'ils ont rompu et qu'elle se trouve
déjà à des milliers de kilomètres de lui